تطبيق تحرير الصور لمسه اي اي شهد اقبالا
هائلا في الاونه الاخيره رغم اطلاقه منذ
عام 28
فالعديد من المشاهير والمؤثرين من مختلف
الدول العالم نشروا صورهم باستخدام
التطبيق عبر منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
المختلفه هذه الميزان شهد تفاعلا واسعا
تستخدم ذكاء الاصطناعي لتحرير الصور على
نحو غير مسبوق حيث تعالج ما بين 10 الى 20
صوره شخصيه بواسطه نموذج الذكر الصناعي
عمليه قد تستغرقوا نحو 40 دقيقه وفي مسع
منها لمعالجه مخاوف الخصوصيه تقول الشركه
التي اطلقت تطبيق ان صور المستخدمين
الشخصيه والنموذج بالصله تحذف نهائيا من
خوادمها فورا انشاء الصور رمزيه السحريه
لان الخبراء يرون ان التطبيق ينتهيك حقوق
النشر وبحسب واشنطوس فالت تطبيق يزيد
مخاطر استغلال وتحرش خاصه انه يسمح لاي
شخص لتنزيل صور اشخاص اخرين
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
التطبيق فكره بسيطه جدا انه يحول الصور
يعالجها ويقدمها المستخدمين وفي التطبيقات
كثيره اساسا تقدم مثل هذه الخدمه باستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي يعني في تطبيقات اساسا
موجوده مجرد ما تيجي تطلب منها بالكتابه
مثلا تقدر تقول لها احتاج صوره شخص مثلا
جالس على كرسي يستمتع بالبحر يبدا الدكاله
الصناعيه يبدا يرسم لك تطبيقات الذكاء
الاصطناعي لمعالجه الصور ما هي همم
جديده بالعكس تطبيقات قديمه لكنه كل تطبيق
ياخذ رواد كل فتره لان يستخدم من قبل
الاشخاص معينين في منصات التواصل اجتماعيه
ويفضلوا الناس انهم يقتدون فيهم يستخدمون
نفس التطبيق اللي هم يستخدمونه
من خلال الناس اللي على السوشيال ميديا
لاحظت انه الصور اللي نزلوها صاروا احلى
اشكال لهم صراحه حقيقه كله احلى بس لفاط
نظري انه اجسادهم صارت مختلفه وهذا امر
خطير قد يكون تركيب الصور في المستقبل على
جسد امراه يعني لا تشبه الامراه التي
نراها في الحقيقه
سهل جدا يمكن اي شخص حاليا قادر انه يغير
في ملامح الجسد ملامح الوجه
همم
تعتمد على الواقع المعزز والفلاثر الخاصه
فيها تخلي الصغير والكبير الصغير وهذه
موجوده زي المدونه الصينيه اللي كانت تطلع
معين وبعدها يوم راح الفلتر بتسوى انها
كبيره جدا في العمر مختلفه عن الصوره اللي
تطلع لهم اياها فتذكاء الاصطناعي اساسا هو
وسيله من الوسائل اللي موجوده في المنصات
التواصل اجتماعيه او حتى في الانترنت
الاستفاده منها من التطبيقات المختلفه
وهذه التطبيقات اللي موجوده واللي تقدر
انت ممكن تستخدمه
تغيير الجسد تغيير الملامح تغيير الوجه هو
شيء قديم موجود حتى من قبل ظهور الصناعي
ذكر اصطناعي سهل فقط العمليه